In addition to what
we have seen already,
Moneyball also discusses
several other things,
for example, how it
is easier to predict
professional success
of college players
than high school players,
that stealing bases,
sacrifice bunting, and
sacrifice flyers are overrated,
and pitching statistics
do not accurately
measure pitcher ability.
Pitchers only
control strikeouts,
home runs, and walks.
Where was baseball in 2002?
The graph on the
left is what we have
seen in the beginning
of this lecture.
So before Moneyball techniques,
analytic techniques,
became more well-known, the
A's were clearly an outlier.
Recall that the A's
are here, compared
to the Red Sox and the Yankees.
Just observe that the A's
had 20 more wins than teams
with equivalent payrolls.
And they had as many wins
as teams like the Red Sox
that have more than
double the payroll.
Where is baseball now?
The A's, in the green dot
here-- and for reference, this
is the Red Sox and the Yankees--
are still an efficient team.
But they only have
about 10 more wins
than teams with
equivalent payrolls.
So specifically, there
are fewer inefficiencies,
because many of
them were discovered
after the book
Moneyball was published.
In fact, the use of analytics
in general in baseball
has now a name
called sabermetrics.
Of course, there has been a
lot of work done in the field.
Baseball Prospectus
is a website devoted
to the analytics of baseball.
New concepts were introduced--
value of a replacement
player, VORP, and defense
independent between statistics,
DIPS.
There's another book
that has been written.
The title of the
book is The Extra 2%:
How Wall Street Strategies
Took a Major League Baseball
Team from Worst to
First, dictating
the story of the Tampa Bay Rays.
And finally, analytics
have been used
in many game-time
decisions in baseball,
for example, the batting order,
changing pitchers, et cetera.
So what is happening
with other baseball
teams and other sports?
So nowadays, every major
league baseball team
has a statistics/analytics
group.
In fact, the Red Sox
implemented quantitative ideas
and won the World Series
for the first time
in 2004, after 86 years.
They in fact tried to
hire Billy Bean in 2003,
who accepted for one day,
but then he changed his mind
and went back to
the Oakland A's.
Analytics are also
used in other sports,
although it is believed
that more teams use
statistical analysis
than is publicly known.
And finally, what is the
edge of using analytics?
Models allow managers
to more accurately value
players and minimize risk.
This is a direct
quote from Moneyball.
"In human behavior, there was
always uncertainty and risk.
The goal of the
Oakland front office
was simply to minimize the risk.
Their solution wasn't perfect.
It was just better than
rendering decisions
by gut feeling."
And a final remark that,
as you have observed
throughout the lecture,
that the model we introduced
are reasonably simple.
They involved regression
ideas, and they did not
involve many variables that
are not that sophisticated.
Yet they led to significant
success of the Oakland A's
and more generally,
for teams that
use the power of
sports analytics.